c'est l'ORS du second débat de ce sens
public volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour même si depuis un
mois et demi c'est évidemment plus
complexe à à à tenir c'est un gros plan
sur l'ingérance russe que je vous
propose il y a un mois on voit
apparaître sur certains murs de Paris
vous vous en souvenez des étoiles de
David de couleur bleue on est en plein
conflit entre Israël et le ramas sur
fond de Regin des actes antisémites
grande émotion en France on apprendra
quelques jours plus tard que derrière C
tag il a euh un des ress sortissant
moldave sans doute commandité par la
Russie Jonathan du
priez c'était il y a quelques semaines
sur fond de conflit entre Israël et le
Hamas des étoiles de David sont taguées
en région parisienne ces tagues seront
ensuite relayés par de faux comptes sur
les réseaux sociaux rapidement les
enquêteurs remontent la piste des
auteurs plusieurs moldaves proche de
réseau prousse ouvertement antisémite
nous avons des éléments extrêmement
précis qui nous nous amène à penser
qu'en effet un commanditaire étranger
est en responsabilité dans cette
situation peu après le qu d'orsek
confirme ses soupçons et condamne
fermement une campagne d'ingérance
numérique de la Russie dans un
communiqué cette nouvelle opération
d'ingérance numérique russe contre la
France témoigne de la persistance d'une
stratégie opportuniste et irresponsable
visant à exploiter les crises
internationales pour semer la confusion
et à créer des tension dans le débat
public en France et en Europe amplifié
par la guerre en Ukraine les ingérences
étrangères surtout Russ et chinoise se
sont multiplié en France ces dernières
années Macron lix lors de la
présidentielle de 2017 François Fillon
recruté par des entreprises russes
cyberattaque sur des hôpitaux selon un
rapport parlementaire la menace est très
élevée mais la prise de conscience très
faible la première des vulnérabilités
c'est la naïveté qui provient d'une
méconnaissance du danger elle concne
aussi bien les décideurs publics élus et
haut fonctionnaires que les entreprises
et les milieux académiques
une naïveté de l'ensemble des acteurs
que confirme le spécialiste des
questions de renseignement Florent
vadiillot lorsqu'on on évoque la naïveté
de la population française et de
certaines catégories en réalité on
pointe du doigt deux sujets très
différents il y a la première ce qui est
un défaut de culture de renseignement de
culture de sécurité et puis la naïveté
c'est aussi que les règles qui sont
requises par les services de
renseignement sont parfois difficilement
applicables à la vie civique pour lutter
contre ces atteintes sans précédent
contre les intérêts français le
Parlement a augmenté de 5 milliards
d'euros le budget du renseignement
militaire à horizon 2030 et pourrait
légiférer de nouveau ingérance étrangère
comment la Russie nous manipule c'est le
thème de notre débat j'accueille
Christian comon bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur du valdemarne membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat ancien président de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et vous
venez d'être nommé envoyé spécial du
président du Sénat chargé des Relations
internationales Christine dugouin
Clément bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuse en géopolitique pour la chair
risque de l'IAE parien Panthéon Sorbonne
Nicolas Kenel bonsoir et bienvenueir
journaliste indépendant auteur de cette
enquête plusieurs années d'enquête pour
ce livre allô Paris ici Moscou publié
aux éditions de Noël évidemment Mathieu
croissandau est resté à mes côtés
éitorialiste politique Christian Cambon
je démarre évidemment sur euh cette
cette affaire de de de tag d'étoil de
David tagué dans les dans les et
certaines rues de Paris c'est euh
viginum le service de l'État chargé de
repérer les ingérences numériques
étrangères qui a fait le lien avec un
réseau euh russe est-ce que ça prouve
que le système fonctionne est-ce qu'on
peut être aussi optimiste que
ça c'est sûr que à la fois le symbole
est fort euh et immédiatement on a pensé
que c'était un que c'était un signe
supplémentaire des des gestes
antisémites qui étaient euh euh qui
étaient affichés euh dans les rues de
nos villes et singulièrement de Paris et
puis l'important c'était de savoir d'où
ça vient c'est toujours la difficulté
c'est de mettre un nom sur les auteurs
de ce genre d'affaire et donc c'est
peut-être effectivement
un le témoignage le signe que des
puissances étrangère utilise ce conflit
pour l'importer en France en se cachant
sous des fonets ou en tous les cas sur
des sous des identités qui ne sont pas
identifiables au premier au premier
abord ouis Christine Clément c'est quoi
l'objectif d'une telle opération
alors vous pouvez en avoir plusieurs
alors notons quand même que sur cette
opération là si on regarde par rapport
on en discutait préalablement par
rapport aux réactions qu'il y avait
notamment le nombre de lik on a pas eu
l'effet qui permettrait de dire qu'on
est sur une opération réussie en terme
en terme d'influence ce que vous allez
faire quand vous êtes en train
d'utiliser la sphère informationnelle
quelle que soit le le niveau dans lequel
vous allez l'utiliser soit vous allez
essayer de diviser hein on va revenir
dans les 4D donc diviser la population
de créer des troubles potentiellement
sur ce que vous pensez ou savez être
déjà des terrains qui sont perturbés
donc quand vous avez une crise VO vous
allez essayer de faire ressortir quelque
chose et soit vous arriver à créer
effectivement de la perturbation une
autre une autre solution peut-être de
gér de bloquer la prise de décision
notamment étatique parce que vous avez
d'autres choses à gérer vous avez une
démultiplication des crises ou vous avez
peur d'une réponse de la population ça
peut-être une autre une autre optique et
puis la troisième option et bien ça va
être tout simplement de euh porter
l'attention sur quelque chose d'autre
qu'un sujet qui vous intéresse vous
précisément donc vous avez vous avez
plusieurs la la liste est longue hein et
vous vous pouvez en avoir plusieurs et
ça tout cela peut-être cumulatif ça peut
être fait avec plus ou moins
d'habileté alors justement est-ce que
c'est est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'habileté dans dans le cas précis
Nicolas Nicolas Kenel est-ce que et
est-ce qu'on sait on est remonté jusqu'à
euh des des agences russes qui seraient
derrière cette opération on en est là
alors euh moi je vais peut-être avoir
une voix un petit peu dissonnante quand
vous avez posé la question de est-ce que
c'est la preuve que le système
fonctionne j'ai presque envie de vous
dire c'est exactement l'inverse c'est la
preuve que le système déconne à plein
régime euh ce qui est intéressant avec
cette opération c'est que c'est une
opération euh on va dire qui est hybride
c'est une opération qui a lieu dans le
monde réel donc dans les rues de Paris
où on tac des étoiles de David mais
c'est aussi une opération qui a lieu sur
le domaine numérique où il y a eu une
tentative d'amplification en fait de la
polémique ce qu'on a remarqué c'est que
la tentative d'amplification sur les
réseaux sociaux est un échec monumental
même au contraire c'est il y a beaucoup
de leçons à tirer de ça justement par
contre dans le monde réel ça a très bien
marché hein il a fallu quelques
centaines d'euros payer de moldaves pour
qu'ils aillent taguer au pochoir dans
les rues de Paris et les mecs ont réussi
à faire l'actualité pendant quoi 3 4
jours une bonne semaine quand même en en
pointant ça c'est de la déstabilisation
à l'ancienne en quelque sorte c'est
c'est euh moi j'en discutais notamment
avec quelqu'un de la dégestion parlerit
même de retour de l'influence à la papa
donc vraiment le retour des méthodes de
la vraiment de la guerre froide parce
que ce genre d'opération on l'a vu aussi
en Allemagne en 1959 et 1960 c'est ce
qu'on avait appelé à l'époque l'épidémie
des S alors ok mais qu'est-ce qui vous
fait dire que le le le enfin no nos
moyens de de défense là je parlais de
viginum donc ce service chargé de
repérer les ingérances Numériques n'a
pas fonctionné viginum a tout à fait
fonctionné viginum a tout à fait
fonctionné par contre c'est toute la
société civile et le système médiatique
qui s emballé à ah oui mais ça on fait
partie ouais mais on fait partie de la
vie de la cité c'estàd que c'est
exactement euh notre faute littéralement
euh si le système s'est complètement
emballé bien aidé au passage par un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui nous a pris
cet exemple pour nous expliquer que
c'était la preuve d'une montée de
l'antisémitisme je sais plus ce qu'il
avait dit mais en tout cas c'était faux
hein manifestement euh et voilà enfin
c'est c'est pas juste une question de
c'est à l'état de gérer c'est aussi aux
journalistes au médias et à la socié
vous c'était pas les seuls tags il y a
eu éto deav bleu sur les murs de Paris
qui relève de cette opération il y a
aussi des tag antisémites en
Normandie un contexte il y a aussi un
contexte qui explique sans doute une
partie de la vigilance et de la réaction
médiatique parce que c'est pas un signal
un non plus ouais moi je suis un peu
plus je suis un peu plus gêné par ça
l'immédiaté de l'information en fait a
des limites ass ses travers et là
typiquement je pense qu'on en a un
exemple particulièrement flagrant
j'entends bien mais quand on parlait des
tag antisémite ça n'était pas seulement
en avit y en avait plusieurs il y avait
plusieurs SIG encore une fois je crois
que c'est valde Normandie mais attention
il est pas du tout question de dire
qu'il y a pas d'augmentation de
l'antisémitisme depuis notamment le 7
octobre la question
c'est on est bien d'accord mais voilà on
on a on a entendu vos arguments à l'un
et à l'autre le couple a-t-il parce que
il y a eu un couple effectivement de
moldave qui a été arrêté est-ce qu'il a
été expulsé trop vite c'est la question
que posait le sénateur Pierrejean
Rochette au ministre de l'Intérieur
justement on était le 15 novembre ici au
Sénat par des incitations à la haine
relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
des puissances étrangères tentent de
déstabiliser notre pays l'affaire des
couples moldaves peignant des étoiles de
David sur des immeuble en est la
dernière illustration monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous dire pourquoi
les intéressés n'ont-ils pas fait
l'objet de poursuite de poursuite pénal
pourquoi ont-ils simplement été expulsés
que savez-vous de leur commanditair dont
la presse semble unanime à désigner les
services de renseignement russe d'autres
actions similaires de la part de ces
mêmes services ont-elles été identifié
au cours de ces dernières années des
conséquences diplomatiques en
seront-elles tirées si cette piste est
confirmée la désinformation et les
manœuvres de la cybergerre sont en train
de tuer la démocratie nous en sommes
depuis longtemps déjà la cible tant à
l'étranger que sur notre propre sol il
nous faut répondre comment le
gouvernement lutte-t-il contre les
tentatives étrangères de
désinformation Christian Cambon je vous
pose à vous la même question que que
posait le le sénateur est-ce qu'ils ont
été exp tu le sais trop rapidement c'est
c'est moldav ou est-ce que finalement
c'était des soufifr il y avait pas
grandchose à en apprendre je pense que
c'était la méthode la plus simple on
allait pas se lancer dans dans dans des
dans des procès ou dans l'instruction
d'un d'une affaire ce sont effectivement
des soufifres qui ont été entièrement
manipulé c'est du reste assez curieux de
mettre en œuvre des moldaves parce que
quand on sait que la Moldavie est un des
pays qui est les plus menacé par la
Russie je dire il y a un espèce de petit
signe contradictoire parce que
sincèrement la la Moldavie est une Act
une de nos inquiétudes à l'heure
actuelle si jamais le conflit ukrainien
s'étendait ce serait certainement la
Moldavie qui en subirait les premiers
les conséquences alors l'une des
questions centrales de ce débat
évidemment c'est pourquoi la France est
ciblée par la Russie vous avez enquêté
pendant plusieurs années Nicolas Kenel
sur sur ce thème pour votre livre à l'OP
Paris ici
Moscou comment on est considéré comment
la France est considérée par les Russes
en quoi ça explique le le fait d'être
éventuellement ciblé ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est quelque
chose qu'on a oublié mais qui date
clairement pas d'hier euh moi je suis
remonté je me suis beaucoup intéressé à
la période de la guerre froide en
l'occurrence pour mon livre et on voit
déjà que à la sortie de la deuxième
guerre mondiale la France était déjà une
cible de choix pour l'URSS pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
évidemment la présence d'un parti
communiste très fort à la sortie de la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale il y avait
aussi quelque part un
anti-américanisme notamment au sein des
élites françaises qui faisait dire que
il y avait peut-être aussi un coup à
jouer par là-bas euh également moi c'est
quel chose ce que j'aime bien ajouter
c'est une tradition française d'un
presse de combat à rebour de la
tradition
anglo-saxonne la presse française a une
tendance à donner une très grande place
aux textes d'opinion dans les dans les
médias aux opinions et c'est je dis pas
que c'est une mauvaise chose mais là
encore c'est un levier qui a qui a été
activé d'ailleurs pendant toute la
période de la guerre froide donc quel et
en plus en plus à l'époque la France
était le siège de vutant donc Chris
Clément est-ce qu'on a une cibre
particulière de la Russie la France
alors euh ou finalement est-ce que il
met de des des politiques similaires
dans beaucoup d'autres pays il y a des
politiques qui sont menées dans
différents pays alors on avait parlé
assez récemment de dOpel ganger qui
était une opération qui avait pour objet
de faire des clones de journaux qui sont
assez réputé qui ont une audience assez
forte pour créer de toutes pièces des
articles qui servaient la la rhtorique
ou le narratif de de Moscou et qui
n'avait évidemment jamais été écrit par
par ses organes de presse libération il
y a pas très longtemps euh voilà et
quand on B les les organes de presse
français ont été touchés mais pas que
l'Allemagne avait été touché l'Italie
avait été touché avec d'ailleurs une
petite modification dans les les les le
narratif qui était utilisé pour coller
encore une fois à ce que l'on attendait
ou du moins à ce que l'on pensait qui
serait reçu avec le plus d'effets sur la
zone qui était visée euh ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que euh on
a une démultiplication des crises alors
avec succès ou pas mais en tout cas euh
il y a un un effort qui est fait et on
est on est
maintenant du moins c'est une approche
que que plusieurs partagent euh dans une
vision où on ne peut pas penser les
crises comme étant décorrélées les unes
des autres et où vous avez au contraire
une espèce de test sur une
démultiplication des crises pour essayer
de voir dans quelle mesure les
Occidentaux puisque là on va parler du
bloc occidental et on en fait partie
sont en capacité ou pas de gérer des
crises qui se démultiplient au même
moment et pardon et excusez-moi et à ce
niveau-là euh si vous voulez on va
pouvoir essayer d'aller euh et bien
attiser ce que l'on a vu hein sur des
éléments existants alors quand vous
allez avoir une opération avec une
hybridaison c'est-à-dire que vous ne l'
menez pas uniquement euh de manière
dématérialisée alors par différents
canaux ce que ça vous permet c'est de
pouvoir totalement maîtriser l'agenda de
ce que vous allez faire vous savez à
quel moment vous allez poser votre
poouchoir qui s'est passé là avec le
pouchoir plus réson encore une fois
caisse de résonance vous avez un terrain
qui est propice on a on a une zone de
tension et cetera et vous allez en jouer
mais le moment vous allez vous-même
poser votre pochoir vous savez à quel
moment ça arrive et ça peut vous
permettre d'essayer de coordonner au
mieux votre action vos réseaux donc de
botes c'est logiciel robot ou quoi que
ce soit d'autre d'ailleurs qui vont
démultiplier l'info juste pour prolonger
la question de Thomas est-ce que la
France est ciblée particulièrement on a
eu quand même en France une chaîne qui
s'appelait ria today puisqu'on parle de
médiia qui traitait de questions de
politique internationale mais aussi de
questions de politique intérieur avec un
un biais en tout cas avec un point de
vue est-ce qu'il y a eu des rechat en
Italie en Espagne en Allemagne alors il
a pard je vais donner la parole à
Christian Cambon je je reprends un tout
petit peu la main parce que sur cette
question de des médias on écoute Ursula
van derlen qui explique pourquoi l'Union
européenne a interdit ces médias je vous
donne la parole juste après sur la
France plus ou moins ciblé on écoute
URSA van
der dans une autre mesure sans précédent
nous allons interdire dans l'Union
européenne la machine médiatique du
kremelin les médias
d'État et sputnic ainsi que leur
filiales ne pourront plus diffuser leurs
mensonges pour justifier la guerre de
Poutine et semer la division de notre
union donc décision européenne Christian
Cambon est-ce que la France est une
cible privilégieuse je pose tout le
temps la même question mais ça permet
d'avoir les des points de vue différents
écoutez moi je personnellement je pense
qu'il faut quand même relativiser un
petit peu les choses tous les pays
occidentaux d' manière générale sont
visés avec des méthodes très différentes
si on compare par exemple ce que fait la
Russie et la Chine c'est les méthodes
sont très différent mais je regarde et
on a effectué au titre de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et au
titre de la Commission d' affaires
étrangères différentes missions regardez
ce qui arrive par exemple aux pays Balt
en Lituanie l'année dernière c'est 65000
attaques cyber c'est-à-dire que
brusquement pendant un weekend vous avez
tout le système bancaire qui est
entièrement paralysé après c'est le
système hospitalier donc je pense que la
Russie j'allais dire procède comme ça a
été dit par des méthodes qui sont assez
traditionnelles c'est c'est l'espionnage
l'espionnage existe filtration alors que
par exemple les les Chinois avec cette
loi de 1971 qui fait que que chaque
chinois sur le territoire national et
surtout dans la diaspora est par
définition un agent du renseignement
chinois et avec des méth des multiplié
et je pense qu'il faut incorporer dans
ces dispositifs bien sûr les
provocations comme celles que l'on vient
de voir mais aussi de nombreuses
tentatives d'infiltration dans les
milieux universitaires dans les milieux
scientifiques dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises moi j'ai un très
grand aussi euh des sous-traitants des
très grandes entreprises de défense
puisque c'est un sujet qu'on a regardé
particulièrement c'est pas tellement euh
Talès ou d'assaut qui sont très très
protégés mais il y a beaucoup il y a des
centaines des milliers d'entreprises qui
sont sous-traitantes il y a là des
véritables sujets il y a des pépites
pour le renseignement étranger et
singulièrement pour ceux qui essayent
c'est le cas des Chinois de s'acaparer
des technologies qui sont maîtrisées par
par les Français je pense que nous
sommes effectivement très surveillés
très écoutés je rappelle tout de même
que ceux qui nous écoutent le plus sont
nos excellents amis américain ce qui
statistiquement été démontré à bien des
à bien des reprises sur les les les
entreprises françaises ciblé Nicolas
Canel dans votre livre vous raconter
l'histoire de je crois c'est la fille
d'un d'un haut
fonctionnaire espion espion russe qui
qui a fait tout un parcours
universitaire en France qui l'a mené
jusqu'à une entreprise dans cette sphère
de la défense c'est ça pas dans la
sphère de la défense dans la sphère de
la sécurité privée sécurité privé
d'accord c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose c'est une histoire de fou c'est
une histoire de fou littéralement bah je
vais VO mon très rapidement en fait moi
je travaillais sur une opération
d'influence du FSB donc du service de
renseignement intérieur russe qui avait
le lieu à Moscou depuis plusieurs années
où il faisait venir des chercheurs des
journalistes tous les ans pour venir
faire de TR jours à Moscou boire un
petit peu de vodka bon il se trouve que
dans le Lot moi je regarde un petit peu
les gens qui sont pointés là-bas j'en
connais un du coup je l'appelle et je
lui demande directement bah alors Michel
qu'est-ce que tu foutais littéralement
avec le FSB peu bizarre pour commencer
une conversation et il me raconte son
aventure de quelques jours il me dit à
un moment il y a quand même quelque
chose de particulier qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai été approché c'était en
2018 ou 2019 par quelqu'un qui m'a dit
très ouvertement appartenir au service
de renseignement russe et qui voulait me
présenter sa petite amie Alexandra euh
qui qui d'ailleurs était là présente à
cette soirée qui normalement était
réservée aux étrangers pour le coup et
il me dit elle a une grande chance c'est
qu'elle a été acceptée à sciencep
l'année prochaine euh parce que elle
s'intéresse beaucoup en fait au
contreterrorisme au Sahel et toi qui
travaill dans le milieu de la défense
est-ce que tu peux lui présenter
quelques gens intéressant à Paris bon il
se trouve que voilà et en fait j'ai pu
découvrir le cas de cette jeune femme
qui en fait était déjà très connu
notamment aux États-Unis euh parce qu'il
se trouve que c'est en fait la fille
d'un espion lui aussi très connu euh du
SVR donc du renseignement extérieur
russe c'està-dire la DGSE pour le coup
l'équivalent de la DGSE et elle avait
déjà été repérée en fait aux États-Unis
je pense que ça pas du tout été vu en
France fait et elle a pu continuer de
progresser fr B elle a fait 6 mois SP
très bien ça s'est très bien passé pour
elle visiblement et ce qui est
fantastique c'est que juste la petite
étiquette Science Po dans le CV a permis
de de huiler la machine quelque part a
permis de se faire embaucher dans la
plus une des plus grandes boîtes de
sécurité privée française je vais je
vais citer le le le rapport de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui est sorti le 13
novembre dernier les ingérences
étrangères s'opèrent de façon de plus en
plus décomplexée concernent tous les
secteurs d'activité de la vie
démocratique à la vie économique on en
parle à l'instant du monde de la
recherche aux espaces numériques des
formes multiples des informations
cyberattaqu espionnage opportunité
juridique lié à
l'extraterritorialité corruption
trahison et cetera est-ce que Christian
Cambon ce rapport marque la fin de la
naïveté d'une certaine façon c'est
exactement ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement il est temps que la
France prenne conscience d'abord qu'elle
est attaquée comme toutes les grandes
puissances mais qu'elle peut aussi
répondre et mettre en œuvre un certain
nombre de mesures de contre-ingérence
euh c'est du reste le sens des crédits
que nous avons accordé dans la loi de
programmation militaire dont j'étais le
rapporteur on a rajouté quand même 5
milliards d'euros ce qui n'est pas une
mince affaire et euh élargir aussi les
recrutements hein on a besoin de
discipline tout à fait nouvell bien sûr
traditionnellement les gens qui parlent
des langues mais même des ethnologues en
fait des gens qui peuvent entrer
véritablement dans les pays dans les
civilisations dans la compréhension des
pays pour voir quels sont les mécanismes
qui qui se mettent en place et je pense
que la France doit effectivement prendre
cette mesure et travailler comme les
autres grandes puissances et jusqu'à
présent on était un peu innocent faut
dire contre ingérence ça ça va jusqu'où
ça peut aller jusqu'à des sanctions
financières si on a repéré desû des
personnalités ou des organismes ça nous
avons fait dans ce rapport dont une
partie n'est pas publique puisqu'il est
remis au Président de la République avec
des des constatations et des
propositions de mesures qui sont
confidentielles et qui restent à la
disposition du chef de l'État mais il y
a un certain nombre de mesures comme par
exemple le dispositif américain la loi
PHA ou effectivement des des des
personnalités étrangères qui sont
conduites à fréquenter des personnalités
publiques ou qui entrent dans des
marchés sensibles et cetera font l'objet
d'une surveillance tout à fait
particulière il suffit juste de leur
mettre le contrôle que l'on met aux élus
al je vais vous dire regarder leurs
avoirs leur demander où est leur
patrimoine quels sont leurs mouvements
bancaires et cetera il y a un certain
nombre de données qu'on peut avoir on
peut procéder à des gels d'avoir on peut
utiliser ce qu'on a utilisé dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme les
algorithmes parce que ça ces
technologies nouvelles commencent à
renseigner considérablement le tout dans
le le respect des libertés publiques
mais en ayant la volonté de de se
défendre et ça je crois que c'est une
c'est c'est c'est maintenant une guerre
qui va falloir mener aussi au titre de
la protection de notre souveraineté
chrise Clément votre avis même question
est-ce qu'on est sorti de l'air de la
naïveté est-ce que ces mesures dont on
parle là cette idée de
contreingérence peut nous permettre
d'être un peu plus efficace on va dire
pour résister euh je pense que il y a
encore beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
faire euh notamment parce que alors on a
parlé d'hybride d'hybridaison enfin tout
ce que l'on veut euh on a commencé à
prendre conscience que la conflictualité
pouvait être en de ça ça donc du seuil
du du passage d'un conflit d'un conflit
armé et que notamment tout ce qui était
opération d'influence pouvait y
participer donc c'est une guerre qui pas
son Guer voilà on pourrait le dire comme
ça l'idée étant que vous allez pouvoir
toucher alors même vous parler de guerre
cognitive hein c'est des choses qui sont
théorisées mais on va pas forcément
toucher que la partie cognition donc
pensé et comportement alors des des
individus ou des groupes sociaux donc
vous pouvez viser un groupe social de
différentes manières voilà vous allez
aussi toucher sur la capacité économique
d'un état sa capacité d'innovation donc
évidemment vous allez pouvoir aller de
manière extrêmement large et notamment
des opérations informationnelles alors
que on parle des attaques à la
réputation ce genre de choses vont
pouvoir aussi toucher des entreprises et
parfois peut-être que on a une
perception encore
incomplète de de ce que l'on peut de ce
que l'on peut encir et de et des types
d'opérations qui peut être mené et juste
un point peut-être pour répondre sur ce
que vous disiez sur RT alors RT est
toujours accessible avec des compétences
numériques voilà avec des compétences
numériques assez basiques hein vous
pouvez complètement y aller et il y a
des canaux qui se sont déployés sur le
continent africain notamment en Afrique
de l'Ouest et pour mémoire pour ceux qui
se rappellent de l'affaire scripal donc
cette ancien espion qui avait été
l'objet d'une tentative assez assez
ratée de de d'empoisonnement par les
services russes et bien les deux
suspects avaient été euh interviewés sur
RT donc canal britannique dans un
exercice assez passif agressif où on
essayait de démontrer que bon ils
étaient pas assez bons techniquement
pour pouvoir être des agents euh voilà
euh donc vous aviez tout ce tout cette
thématique là qui servait aussi bien et
qui plus que pour nous à être une une
recapitalisation donc il y a toujours
des relais médiatiques même sils sont un
peu un peu moins exposés c'est c'est ce
que je comprendsz tjours vous en avez
toujours et en plus c'est un marché qui
est extrêmement concurrentiel où vous
allez même avoir affaire à parfois des
sous-traitants ce qui peut parfois
générer des des quakques en terme de
coordination HM euh vous parliez de
cyberattaque à l'instant je vous propose
de d'entendre un témoignage celui du
député européen Raphaël Luxman qui
préside la Commission spéciale sur
l'ingérance étrangère dans l'ensemble
des processus démocratiques de l'Union
européenne et il cite il rappelle le
blocage subi par l'hôpital de corbeille
et son il y a le cas de l'hôpital de
corbeille et son qui euh a défrayé à
juste titre la chronique puisque pendant
plusieurs mois l'hôpital a
été capacité c'està-dire qu'il y a des
conséquences extrêmement concrètes les
médecins n'ont plus accès au dossier des
malades et donc ça bloque le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital il y a le
cas de l'Agence européenne du médicament
par exemple en pleine pandémie qui a été
attaqué par des hackeurs russes et donc
c'est ces cyber attaque elles sont
souvent liées à des groupes qui sont
liés au Grou les services de
l'armée de l'armée russe et
ell elles font basculer si vous vous
voulez la question des ingérences dans
la question de la guerre hybride et
elles effacent la différence qui est
constitutive de notre analyse du monde
entre état de paix et état de guerre
comment vous qualifiez vos relations
avec un régime qui attaque vos hôpitaux
en pleine pandémie est-ce que c'est la
paix est-ce que c'est la guerre et on
est bien en peine de répondre à C
question on est en guerre hybride c'est
ce que je je comprends et ce que je
retiens de cette intervention de Raphaël
gluxman Nicolas canenel on a beaucoup
parlé de la Russie on a un tout petit
peu grâce à chisan Cambon parlé de la
Chine est-ce qu'ils sont pas encore plus
efficaces que les Russes les Chinois
dans cette dans dans ces actions
d'ingérance ou de déstabilisation c'est
pas la même approche c'est pas la même
approche parce que c'est déjà de base
c'est pas les mêmes pays euh moi il y a
quelque chose que j'aime bien rappeler
quand on parle de la Russie c'est que la
Russie c'est un pays qui a un PIB de
1700 milliards donc on va dire peu au
prou la moitié de ce qu' la France et
l'Union européenne c'est 14500 milliards
euh la Chine par contre contre c'est
quand même un autre c'est une autre
catégorie de poids je pense je peux me
tromper je pense que l'influence
chinoise en France est beaucoup plus
profonde beaucoup plus établie et quand
les Russes sont un peu condamnés à
essayer de recruter pour être agent
d'influence concrètement le fond du
panier hein il recrutent des politiciens
de 3è zone ils ont pas les moyens de
faire plus littéralement on regarde un
petit peu ceux qu'on soupçonne de rouler
pour les Russes bon ça ça crève pas le
plafond que ce soit vis-àvis des PO
politiciens des avocats des journalistes
à chaque fois on est sur on est quand
même sur le fond du panier quoi la Chine
je suis pas sûr la Chine a tout à fait
les moyens d'être beaucoup plus
persuasif d'un point de vue financier
alors j'entends votre argument sauf que
si on regarde quand même Matthieu la
liste des des anciens dirigeants
politiques européens qui ont été
recrutés par la Russie il y a quand même
quelques grands noms bah le fond du
panier après oui non en fait c'est une
zone de grille on âge entre un peu
influence et ingérence alors en tout cas
côté français on pense évidemment au
plus Russ au fil d'entre eux euh
l'ancien Premier ministre François
Fillon hein qui a quittit la politique
après sa défite à la présidentielle et
qui avait été recruté en 2021 par deux
sociétés russes du secteur de l'énergie
et de la pétrochimie l'une appartenant à
100 % l'État russe l'autre étant dirigé
par un grand ami de Vladimir Poutine
hélas pour lui j'ai envie de dire cette
coopération a pris fin assez rapidement
puisqu'il a démissionné un peu contraint
et forcé par la polémique euh au
lendemain de l'invasion de l'Ukraine euh
sans avoir dit-il touch
le moindre centime d'argent russe il a
été auditionné à l'Assemblée en mai
dernier François Fillon il faignait de
ne pas voir où était le problème
regardez à partir du moment où j'ai
quitté la vie publique je veux le
rappeler je veux dire je suis une
personne privée et je mène ma Carrère
professionnel comme je l'entends si j'ai
envie de vendre des rillettes sur la
place sur la Place Rouge je vendrai des
rillettes sur la Place Rouge je le dis
parce que je cette idée que parce que
j'ai été premier ministre je n'ai plus
le
droit d'avoir quelques activité
professionnelle que ce soit ce qui est
pas du tout ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est ce que pense un certain nombre
d'observateurs ça n'est pas pour moi
pour moi pour moi acceptable alors quand
on lui demandait à François Fillon
pourquoi il avait été recruté pourquoi
il avait été choisi selon lui c'était
son expérience d'ancien Premier ministre
et d'ancien ministre son regard sur la
situation internationale qui pouvait
intéresser les Russes j'ai envie de dire
modeste trop modeste François Fillon
peut-être ou naïf trop naïf parce qu'il
évidemment il le sait aussi son carnet
d'adresse possibilité sa capacité à
mobiliser des réseaux et puis son sa
voie médiatique même si vrai là je vous
rejoins qu'elle est moindre en 2021
qu'elle deétait en 2017 mais on sait
bien que tout ça c'est ce qui intéresse
les Russes ou en tout cas les puissances
étrangères quand elles ont recours à des
à des anciens politiques et François
Fillon est loin d'être le seul retraité
de la politique à avoir cédé aux sirènes
du crémelin on va donner quelques
exemples étranger oui alors le plus
célèbre évidemment Gerard schreer un
l'ancien chancellier allemand recruté
après son départ du poste de pr runiste
par les géants russes Rosneft puis
Gasprom et puis c'est c'est lui quand il
était chancelier qui avait poussé à
Nordstream 2 voilà qui avait orienté la
la la politique énergétique allemande
donc il y avait un côté retour
d'ascenseur une telle réussite que les
russesx mêmes ont donné un nom à ce type
de recadrage ou de recasage c'était la
chreudurisation de la classe politique
européenne proche de Poutine il refuse
de démissionner au lendemain de
l'invasion de la guerre en Raine lui il
plaide alors pour la modération pour les
sanctions quand même al il y a d'autres
exemples encore oui autres pays aut
cible en Autriche l'ancien chancelier
conservateur volgang schlusel est lui
aussi passé par le conseil des
directeurs de loil le plus grand
producteur de pétrole russe
l'ex-ministre des Affaires étrangères
autrichiennees aussi Karine knisel qui
avait été qui elle avait invité Vladimir
Poutine à son mariage elle a éter r un
temps chez Rosneft elle aussi alors tous
ne sont pas évidemment devenus des
porte-parel des porte-paroes pardon
officiels du du kremelin ce serait trop
simple mais tous ces retraité doré on
ont quand même condamné mollement
l'invasion de l'Ukraine ou renvoyer dos
à dos la Russie et l'autant expliquant
aussi pour la plupart d'entre eux que la
politique de sanction n'était pas
forcément une bonne idée euh comme le
soulignait l'eurodéputé Raphaël gluxman
qu'on vient d'entendre euh les retraites
d'aué versées à nos élites pour des par
des régimes hostiles à nos valeurs et à
nos intérêts stratégiques sont un
véritable problème un problème dont un a
manifestement pas encore trouvé euh la
solution merci Mathieu Christian quand
quand quand François Fillon dit devant
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
si j'ai envie de vendre des riettes sur
la Place Rouge je vendrai des riettes
sur la Place Rouge est-ce que c'est pas
quand même une sorte de grand bras
d'honneur aux citoyens français écoutez
moi je laisse à François Fillon la
paternité de ce genre de propos que que
je ne tiendrai évidemment pas je pense
simplement que dans nos régimes où dans
nos pays où les où l'information circule
quand même assez bien François Fillon a
été depuis assez longtemps identifié
comme un ami de la Russie on le sait et
à partir de ce moment-là les
déclarations qu'il peut faire elles
prennent aussi une coloration j'allais
dire naturellement c'est pour ça que je
trouve que ce que fait la Chine est plus
discret et peut-être plus efficace parce
parce que la Chine elle n'investit pas
enfin pas peut-être telle ou telle
personnalité mais elle n'investit pas de
la même manière elle utilise la
politique du rateau c'estd elle ramasse
toutes les données hein il est du reste
plus que conseiller y compris quand vous
êtes en voyage officiel en Chine de ne
surtout pas partir par exemple avec
votre téléphone parce que même éteint
votre téléphone est entièrement visité
donc c'est c'est c'est un dispositif où
toutes les données c'est on parle de de
plus d'un million de gens qui sont
spécialisés en Chine pour récupérer les
données de l'Occident mais des données
absolument anodines mais qui un jour ou
l'autre peuvent servir parce que la
carrière de la personne euh peut être
utile de la même manière l'entrrisme
dans les universités euh et
singulièrement des universités
scientifiques c'est c'est beaucoup plus
efficace que la parole de tel ou tel
dont on sait déjà qu'il est mais est-ce
qu'il faudrait interdire à d'ancien
Premier ministre ou d'ancien président
de de de ensuite remplir des fonctions
administrateurs dans des régimes hostil
il y a en France suffisamment
d'organismes qui qui surveillent les
élus il y a la Haute Autorité de la vie
publique il y a oui mais quand il est il
dit lui-même je je je suis plus
responsable public il faudrait
effectivement un délai de un délai de
carence si je veux dire comme pour les
haut-fonctionnaires qui ne peuvent pas
rentrer dans le privé euh dans dans dans
dans des sociétés dont ils ont eu
l'occasion de s'intéresser je pense
effectivement qu'il y a certainement des
mesures à prendre dans dans ce domaine
ça touche me semble-t-il un nombre assez
restreint de responsable politique qui
l'assume y compris sur le plan éthique
ça j' peux pas euh je peux pas évoqu qui
est cette dimension du problème qui leur
appartient mais je pense que il y a il y
a des contrôles et euh en France nous
avons nous nous devons par exemple dans
les déclarations d'intérêt que nous moi
je viens d'être élu j'ai rempli une
épaisseur de documents me demandant tous
les intérêts que je peux avoir dans tous
les domaines donc il y a tout de même un
contrôle bon et ça veut pas dire
effectivement que on peut pas raconter
n'importe quoi mais enfin alors cette
question de de des relais politiques on
va dire de de de l'influence russe
évidemment elle nous mène aussi au
rassemblement national et à Marine Le
Pen euh qui elle aussi répondait devant
la commission d'enquête on écoute
l'ancienne candidate du RN je signe un
prêt avec une banque hein je signe pas
un prêt avec Vladimir Poutine voilà
sinon tous vous avez signé des prêts
avec Macron bah oui non mais d'accord
mais je veux dire ça voudrait dire que
quand on signe un prêt avec une banque
française euh on signe pas avec l'accord
d'Emmanuel Macron mais quand on signe
avec une banque qui est moitié de chèque
moitié rus
je
avec ça ne m'engage absolument à rien et
si ça m'avait engagé à quelque chose
monsieur le Président je n'aurais pas
signé ce prêt c'est clair je ne l'aurais
pas
signé Nicolas Kenel est-ce que dans
votre enquête qui a duré je crois 4 ans
c'est ça vous avez croisé beaucoup de
représentants du rassemblement national
en enquêtant sur les réseau d'influence
russe ou pas d'Ille je vais vous citer
Nicolas Lerner le directeur de la DGSI
qu justement devant la Commission de
lutte contre les ingérances étrangères à
l'Assemblée nationale euh il a eu une
phrase que moi j'aime beaucoup quand il
a dit que il n'y a pas de parti en
France sous influence mais il y a des
individus sous influence moi ce que j'ai
fait dans mon enquête c'est je me suis
astreint quand même à essayer d'éviter
au maximum de parler des gens
directement parce que à chaque fois
qu'on parle d'un individu X ou Y de X
parti ou y parti la focale va
automatiquement se braquer là-dessus moi
je me suis intéressé vraiment au système
qui permettait potentiellement à ces
agents d'influence d'évoluer
c'est-à-dire dans tous les ministères
qui est chargé potentiellement de les de
de les débusquer concrètement du point
de vue judiciaire comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour potentiellement judiciariser
les cas quels sont les problèmes qui
peuvent y avoir du coup j'ai essayé de
raconter un système plus que des
individu en particulier d'accord cette
histoire de prêt Christian Cambon votre
avis là-dessus je pense que ça pose un
vrai problème moi je suis j'ai quand
même une expérience pour mêtre présenter
à très nombreuses élections et il faut
quand même savoir au jour d'aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a quasiment plus de banques
qui se propose de prêter dans le cadre
légal euh les les pour les dépenses
électorales moi je viens de vivre cette
expérience il y a 3 mois ma banque euh
où j'ai de quoi garantir le modeste prêt
que je voulais faire pour la clarté et
la transparence m'a dit non ça ne nous
intéresse pas on prête pas aux
politiques et donc euh il y a une
promesse du président de la République
hein sur la moralisation de la vie
publique qui consistait à créer
justement en s'appuyant je crois sur la
Caisse des Dépôts une banque qui est se
spécialiserait dans le prêt pour la vie
publique et ça je pense que c'est un
effort de moralisation très important
parce que ce que dit Madame Le Pen avec
laquelle je n'ai aucune proximité aucune
hein mais je dis que son problème est
réel aucune banque ne n'a proposé alors
que c'est un parti qui est inscrit dans
dans la vie démocratique c'est c'est un
fait c'est comme ça aucune banque ne lui
a proposé un prêt alors maintenant
qu'après des banques étrangères SE
saisiss de cette opportunité pour se
pour se pour se créer un lien
particulier mais je pense que la bonne
réponse à ça ça serait un organisme
public ça peut être la Caisse des dépôts
ou n'importe quoi mais qui prête de
l'argent aux élus de toute sensibilité
au quel que soit quel que soit leur
appartenance de telle sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas la possibilité pour ces pour ces
candidats d'être approchés par des
banques étrangères qui évidemment
trouveront le bénéfice de leur prêter de
l'argent alors je voudrais qu'on termine
ce ce ce débat il nous reste quelques
minutes pour se projeter vers les Jeux
Olympiques qui vont se dérouler à Paris
et en France l'été prochain je vous
propose de de voir ces messages on été
publié sur sur Twitter c'était ce
mercredi 15 novembre un collectif de
lutte contre les discours de haine en
ligne qui s'appelle les sleeping Giants
alerte sur une probable nouvelle
campagne de déstabilisation orchestrée
par la Russie il cite une vidéo
faussement attribué à une milice turque
qui compile des images du massacre
d'athlète israélien au je de Munich de
72 et qui se termine par une évocation
des jeux de paris no time for games pas
de temps pour les jeux et on voit aussi
des graph Kity qui dresse un parallèle
entre les jeux de de 1972 et ceux de
2024 vous le voyez un fusil d'assaut qui
passerait symboliquement de la main
municoise à la main parisienne Christine
dugouin Clément on parle d'un false flag
des de cette milice turque là des loups
gris de Turquie donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que d'autres éventuellement
les Russes cherchent à faire porter le
chapeau à ce groupe la la la la
paternité de ces de ces informations de
ces fausses informations qu quand on va
parler d'une d'une attaque sous faux
drapeau ou d'une FSE flag attaque alors
ça va être la même chose quand vous
parlez d'attaques cyber qui vont toucher
les systèmes ou informationnels voire
même d'opération militaire le but étant
de faire croire que l'action que vous
avez diligenté ou mené est en fait le
produit d'une tierce personne ou d'un
groupe différent si vous voulez le but
étant de détourner les les l'pre et les
conséquences de votre action de votre
personne organisation ou
structure par on voit derrière vous vous
l'avezu devant cette image on a
l'impression qu'elle a été effectivement
taguée sur un mur en France a priori
c'est pas le cas voyez on est dans on
est à ce degré de manipulation alors ça
c'est c'est enfin c'est pas quelque ce
degré c'est quelque chose d'assez
basique en réalité hein si enfin c'est
ce qu'on va appeler de la de tout
simplement de la
décontextualisation alors soit vous
pouvez effectivement créer une image de
toute pièce soit vous pouvez les
décontextualisé on en a eu beaucoup vous
allez montrer par exemple l'image d'un
charnier vous allez expliquer que ça se
passe en Ukraine à tel moment bon bah
c'est un vrai charnier c'est une vraie
photo sauf que bah c'est dans les
Balcans par exemple voilà donc vous
pouvez aussi simplement prendre un
élément réel et le le transporter dans
le temps dans l'époque o donc là
l'objectif c'est c'est de nous dire
c'est de faire c'est de mettre quoi de
d'infusé de la peur au sein de la
société française sur une menace
terroriste pendant les Jeux Olympiques
vous on va voir un événement massif qui
va avoir qui va avoir une couverture
médiatique extrêmement importante qui va
se dérouler dans une période
géopolitique qui est particulièrement
féconde si ce n'est tendu donc
évidemment vous avez des enjeux mais qui
seront russes et pas forcément que et
vous avez des effet d'opportunisme
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez tout à fait
avoir une stratégie globale qui est
soutenue par un état et puis des petits
acteurs qui soit vont potentiellement
essayer de monter une action pour
essayer de se faire embaucher par un
plus gros en démontrant à quel point ils
ont été efficaces dans certains cas mais
c'est un marché concurrentiel comme un
autre malgré tout soit vous allez
pouvoir simplement servir d'autres
micros inérêts ou ou autres donc il est
évident que à chaque fois qu'on a une
grosse manifestation qui a une
couverture médiatique importante et qui
va réunir des enjeux de sûreté
importants et bien forcément les
services de sécurité et police et
gendarmerie le savent sont
particulièrement attentif à ce qui peut
se passer alors il y a peut-être une
partie petite partie de nos
téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas connu ne
se souviennent pas de du 1972 des
athlètes israéliens pris en otage tué
par un commando palestinien donc on on
voit bien eff effectivement la résonance
avec l'actualité
aujourd'hui Nicolas Kenel que savez-vous
de cette opération là si vous avez
peut-être queourd B absolument rien
d'accord vous AZ que je suis pas le
seul non en fait ce que je trouve assez
intéressant c'est que aujourd'hui on
sait même pas on narrive pas à confirmer
en tout cas pour rien de savoir si c tag
dans la ville de Paris on sait que c'est
des tags qui montent des rues bien
précises à Paris c'est dans le 20e
arrondissement et le 5e arrondissement
les premières photos sont apparues le 8
novembre mais on en a pris conscience à
partir je crois du v quand Mme il a lase
de temps il a quand même 12 jours et
c'est à partir de de c'est 12 jours plus
tard en fait que les faux comptes russes
sur les réseaux sociaux se sont activés
pour diffuser ça largement c'est même
arrivé dans le canal telégram de on
n'est pas sûr que ces tags ont été
physiquement fait sur des murs parisiens
c'est ce que vous nous dites peut-être
que oui rép pas été montré par les
médias en T les cas ou non mais alors
contrairement aux étoiles de David du
coup pour une fois pardonnez-moi
l'expression on n'a pas pété un plomb
hmm euh Christian Cambon sur cette voilà
menace spécifique de déstabilisation lié
aux Jeux Olympique est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez évoqué à
l'occasion de j'imagine que oui à
l'occasion de des différentes
délégations ouou tout fait je peux vous
dire que à la fois au niveau de la
défense au niveau du renseignement euh
euh tout le monde est sur les dents et
plus la plus la date s'approche plus la
mobilisation est grande et je pense
qu'on va avoir des provocations et
peut-être des provocations inattendues
ceci poser je pense qu'il faut aussi
être suffisamment lucide c'est compliqué
c'est difficile pour ne pas charger
systématiquement vous savez la Russie
elle va rester là où elle est et un jour
on l'espère tous les choses vont changer
en Russie mais elle fait partie ENF
c'est notre voisin hein et donc on peut
pas mettre au band des nations ça vous
savez ce genre de réaction c'est lié
aussi au fait qu'il y avait des mots
d'ordre pour que la Russie ne participe
pas aux Jeux Olympiques donc voyez il a
une réaction donc c'est très difficile
de rester à la fois lucide et objectif
pour savoir effectivement que la Russie
utilise ces ces modes de stabilisation
comme d'autres pays le font et que
malgré tout il faut avoir un œil sur ce
qui se passe en Russie parce que un jour
c'est un souit qu'on peut émettre les
choses changeront et on reprendra je
l'espère avec la Russie une relation
vous dites il y a pas que la Russie qui
va utiliser les Jeux Olympiques pour
éventuellement
il y a pas que la Russie il y a la Corée
du Nord qui est très habile il y a la
Turquie qui peut le faire d'une autre
manière ENF il y a beaucoup de gens qui
peuvent être concernés non pas par cette
affaire spécifique mais par des
déstabilisations sur les pays
occidentaux euh nous vivons nous sommes
un peu au cœur de de ces tentatives
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vais rappeler
évidemment Nicolas Canel le titre de
votre livre allô Paris ici Moscou livre
publié aux éditions de Noël merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité à
Sens public et à public sénal l'imité de
la matinale demain notez-le c'est Thomas
ménager qui sera face à Orian mansini
pour aménager le porte-parole du groupe
rassemblement national bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous merci
[Musique]